si comme moi tu peux voir nos amis et sa
famille dit cui j'ai vu et nous avons
rendez vous jeudi prochain
tu ne passeras pas du tout s'était passé
la soupe est bonne en général non
seulement la sarre et valdes les troupes
sont fraîches et j'avais l'habitude vous
monsieur je crois de la cuisine
militaire puisque vous avez passé une
trentaine d'années dans l'armée mais la
cuisine d'un général tout de même alors
mis c'est surtout la cuisine popote et
rarement à la table de généraux le mari
de valérie andré un ancien colonel de
l'armée de l'air s'est rarement assis à
la table des généraux aujourd'hui c'est
chose faite
madame le médecin général lui a préparé
ce midi des tomates et de la salade mal
à ces zones est paraît-il avant de
retourner à sa base par et ses deux
étoiles
la première général de l'armée française
avoue bien volontiers qu'elle n'est pas
un cordon bleu
vous êtes resté très simple pour un
général pas de chauffeur pas des deux
camps en fait à part vos étoiles vous
êtes presque une femme comme les autres
mais j'espère bien être une femme comme
les autres ce n'est pas parce que je
suis médecin général que j'ai
l'intention de changer quoi que ce soit
dans ma manière d'être lu dans ma vie
mais est ce que vous croyez que vous
avez eu beaucoup de chance de devenir
général ou au contraire est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est de le cheminement
normal de votre carrière
je vous dirais que je me suis toujours
donné à fond pour mon métier j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance d'avoir un métier qui
m'a autant passionnés et des malgré tout
je reconnais que on ne peut pas on ne
devient pas systématiquement général si
vous voulez j'ai beaucoup de chance
cette petite femme frêle et souriante ne
doit pas seulement ses étoiles à la
chance
né en 1922 à strasbourg elle s'est
engagée à l'âge de 25 ans comme médecin
capitaine en indochine
on commande des hélicoptères ou des
avions qu'elle apprend à piloter
elle participe à 120 missions de guerre
en extrême-orient et assurent
l'évacuation de cent soixante cinq
blessés en algérie
elle effectue 365 mission comme médecin
et pilotes malgré la croix-rouge fans
sur son appareil
on ne l'épargnait pas dit elle lors des
évacuations sanitaires breveté
parachutiste décoré de la croix de
guerre avec cette citation commandeur de
la légion d'honneur
valérie andré totalise trois mille deux
cents heures de vol
aujourd'hui le général n'a pas perdu la
main
on était jusqu'à présent un seul visage
humain en général dans l'armée française
que ressentez-vous après cette
invitation la jalousie à genève parce
que l'on était plus logique pour larbi
carrure et il est certain que dans
l'armée comme dans l'autre ce bed ont la
passion peut plus me lancer de voir
confier est ce que te laisse imaginer un
jour que je peux un peu générale
dirigent l'opération coeur bien je lui
répondrais d'abord que nous espérons y
aura pas fier mais enfin ce qui vient de
se produire
il faudrait d'abord savoir qu'elle se
présenterait depuis ce genre de
responsables et souhaiterait confier ses
prestations notamment la belle entre
pouvait espérer obtenir ces deux étoiles
en 1975 lors de l'année de la femme
le gouvernement aura préféré attendre
son anniversaire pour la nommer général
le jour même où elle entre dans sa 55e
année